So one of the the YouTube
viewers asked me to
do this problem.
And it looked like a
pretty good problem.
So I thought I would record
a quick video on it.
So the problem's this: f of g
of x -- hope I get this right
-- is equal to 2 times the
square root of x squared plus
1 minus 1, all of that
over the square root of x
squared plus 1 plus 1.
And f of x is equal to 2x
minus 1 over x plus 1.
And the question is, if we know
that f of g of x is equal to
this fairly complex-looking
expression, and that f of x is
equal to this, than
what is g of x?
Well, we could actually
do this problem by kind
of just looking at it.
Because f of g of x, what we do
is, we took -- everywhere we
see an x, we replace
it with g of x.
So, f of g of x would
look like this.
And I'll do it in
another color.
So, let's see. f of g of x.
And let's say we don't
know what g of x is.
Would be like this.
Everywhere where we saw an x,
we replace it with g of x.
Because -- so it would
be 2 times g of x.
Minus 1 over g of x plus 1.
And we also know that f of g
of x is equal to this thing.
Right?
Here we just took the g of x
and put it in of f of x, and
we wrote the g of x
in the expression.
But we know that that is equal
to this expression up here.
So that is also equal to 2
times the square root of x
squared plus 1, minus
1, all of that over x
squared plus 1 plus 1.
And I think, now, at this
point, you can kind
of pattern match.
And you can see what g of x is.
2 times something
minus 1, right?
2 times something minus 1.
2 times something minus 1 in
the numerator, and that's
something plus 1 in
the denominator.
And that's something plus
1 in the denominator.
So in either case, we have g
of x is equal to the square
root of x squared plus 1.
And, actually, in the example
he sent me, there was
a bunch of choices.
And if you were given the
choices, then all you have to
really do is take each of the
choices for g of x and replace
them in for x in
this expression.
And then see which of those
choices for g of x ends
up with this expression.
Actually, we can do it.
I mean, he gave the choice
-- well, let me see.
Let me delete some of this.
I want to do it, let's
see if I can do it in
-- oh, there we go.
Better.
All right.
So, I wanted you to see that
you could do the problem
even if you weren't
given any choices.
But if you are given choices,
the problem actually even
becomes a little bit
more straightforward.
So the choices were --
actually, I erased some of it.
It was given that f of x is
2x minus 1 over x plus 1.
And then they said, which of
the following is g of x.
So, g of x is equal to.
And they give these choices.
a), square root of x, b),
square root of x squared plus
1, which we just figured out
was actually the answer.
c), x, d), x squared.
And then e), x squared plus 1.
And the way you would do this
problem if, you, just by
looking at it you didn't -- the
method we just saw, saw that if
you just replaced x with square
root of x squared plus 1
everywhere, then you'd
get f of g of x.
The other option is, you just
take each of these and say well
what is f of -- if you replaced
x with this term everywhere,
what do you get?
Well, then you'd get 2 times
square root of x minus 1 over
the square root of x plus 1.
And that's not what
we have up here.
Then if you took this and you
replaced for x everywhere -- so
if you took this expression,
you replaced it for x
everywhere, then you would
get this expression.
So you would know that
this would be the answer.
If you just replaced x with x,
you would just get -- you would
just get this over again,
which does not equal this.
So that doesn't work.
If g of x was this, then f of g
of x would be -- let's see,
everywhere we see an x, you'd
put an x squared, so it
would be 2x squared minus 1
over x squared plus 1.
Which does not equal this.
And similarly, if g of x was
this term right here, then f of
g of x would be would be 2
times x squared plus 1 minus 1
over x squared plus 1 plus 1.
Which you can simplify
a bit, but that still
doesn't equal this.
And so this, once again, if
you're given the choices,
you just try this out.
And if you replace this
expression everywhere,
where you see an x, right?
Everywhere where you see an
x, and you replace it this
expression, you get these and
that's what the question,
essentially, was asking us.
So, hopefully I didn't
confuse everyone too much.
And hopefully this was
helpful for the viewer
who asked me to do this.
I'll see you all later.
Bye.